all right Frank Reich talking to Mike
Tirico and look Phillip Rivers at as I
said last week at 25 million dollars for
him 25 million dollars for Brees 25
million dollars for Brady Rivers should
be wearing a ski mask because I don't
think at this point he's in that same
class as them we saw I think the
disintegration last year are they
justified in thinking that there is a
major upgrade from from Jacobi Brissette
to Phillip Rivers in Indianapolis Chris
well yeah I do I think they're they are
justified of that you know Phillip
Rivers first off yes it wasn't perfect
last year we saw some bad interceptions
it's the big moments and that's plagued
him a little bit you know towards the
end of his career with the Chargers in
general other than two years ago when
they went 12 and 4 but I still think man
he's a hell of a playmaker still he's
still tough and fearless in the pocket
and willing to push the ball down the
field and I think that this is the most
well-rounded offense he's been a part of
in a number of years you know it's not
gonna always have to be about him making
big plays in the pass game but this
offensive line and you know what they
did in the draft and running backs and
of course some receivers that they have
on the team that are talented as well
already I look at it as being a better
support system around Phillip Rivers
especially with the pass protection and
the threat of the running game behind
you know the big blue wall there so I
get it and I certainly don't think if I
was a head coach or Chris Ballard or
anything like that I don't know if I
could have trusted Jacoby percent to go
into the year the way I looked at the
end of the season last year you know
when he came back from the injury it was
really really shaky and I think
ultimately that's probably what led
Indianapolis to kind of investigating
the quarterback market but what if he
was just still injured right I feel so
bad for the guy they started five and
two and we were talking about what a
brilliant move it was for them to extend
the contract to Jacoby percent and he's
their guy and they're not gonna miss a
beat from Andrew Luck to Jacoby percent
he suffers the knee injury against
Pittsburgh he misses some time and then
he comes back and and he and we see a
decline and and it's like not even
taking into consideration that maybe his
knee was still messed up and I feel like
the
team didn't take that into consideration
either well no I thought you know listen
that's very real first off when you do
miss time it's not always easy to just
jump back out in there oh there's my dog
barking somebody must be walking to the
house but it's not always easy just to
jump back in there you know and just hit
the ground running again and execute on
a really high level it's not man my dog
somebody's barking back there yeah but
either way he's coming back here your
check bounced your barbara's laughs yeah
but but I think you know again might at
the end of the season it wasn't just
like there was a number of bad throws
bad decisions missed targets to where I
think it went beyond just the normal oh
he's injured and we're gonna give him
the benefit of the doubt I think there
was some really perplexing things going
on there and I just remember a few times
watching games - watching Frank Reich
and him sitting there going like oh he
doesn't know what to call right now
because he doesn't trust this
quarterback I just felt like I saw that
look on his face a number of times
towards the end of the year but I think
it's possible Chris and look you would
know better than I'd on this but if you
come back from that injury maybe earlier
than you should have and the injury is
affecting you and your game is starting
to dip and you start to maybe press a
little even if the knee is better you
feel like you're in a rut that you just
can't get out of that nothing is working
what is wrong with me what is happening
here and the next thing you know you
completely fall apart no I mean you're
exactly right and I've been there in
that situation like I said it is not
easy you're right you know cuz you come
back and then you probably wasn't 100%
healthy we know you don't get to
practice and all sudden you're in a game
and you're like whoa I'm not comfortable
here let alone I don't feel totally a
hundred percent oh man we've been losing
we got to win this game I got to start
pushing the envelope and you're right it
could filter into making a lot of bad
decisions or doing stupid things at the
quarterback position I think ultimately
what we saw here is the a team that
Chris Ballard or Frank Reich probably
look at and go where we think we're
ready for a payoff run and maybe they
view themselves as a superb
all contender and maybe the guy like
Philip Rivers walking in the locker room
gives the rest of the team that
confidence and Creedence just to be like
okay we got a guy that's you know been
there done that yeah he hasn't got two
Super Bowls but he's in the AFC
championship game and a lot of playoff
games more of a proven commodity to
maybe take advantage what the team has
and give it that little extra confidence
that a great quarterback like Philip
Rivers or Brady or Brees can give a
locker room
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports